well every week thousands of nevadans
file their weekly unemployment claims
and as they do that
the amount of money available in
nevada's treasury fund shrinks
joe mohler shows us that this will
impact those who are waiting for those
weekly checks
joe
i spoke to an unemployment research
expert who explained as those funds do
go
down unemployed nevadans should not be
worried if their benefits will continue
i have not been successful yet to get
through the phone lines at dieter
peggy lyser is a restaurant server in
las vegas she's waited months for
unemployment benefits
i don't make enough money to pay april
may and june's rent
i've borrowed from family members i've
i've tapped out every well i know and i
don't know
what more to do she is like many others
in nevada waiting for adjudication and
money from dieter
as more people get paid the less money
there is in the state's unemployment
insurance treasury account
nevada had about one and a half years of
reserves
that's actually much higher than most
states at the beginning of the pandemic
the nevada unemployment insurance
treasury fund had about 2 billion
dollars
as of the last update from veda there
was nearly 800 million
more than 100 million disbursed weekly
if nevada
exhausts the reserves in the treasury
account then the treasury will loan
money to the state
to pay benefits chris o'leary from the
w.e of john institute for employment
research says
unemployed nevadans should not be
worried so anyone
in the state who's entitled to
unemployment benefits will be paid those
benefits
other states have already started
borrowing from the treasury that is
money that will have to be paid back
employers in the state will pay off the
borrowing
sometime in the future after the crisis
is over
o'leary says it's too early to tell if
employers here in nevada will have to
pay more into unemployment insurance
than they did before the pandemic
reporting live joe mohler 8 news now